como ya saben me llamo martín bustamante
y hoy soy escritor
facultad que mantuve oculta durante casi
toda mi vida
oculta porque si yo decía en mi barrio
que me gustaba escribir
sobre todo en aquella época no tenía
ningún tipo de oportunidad
me crié en un barrio
en donde el delito es el protagonista o
era el protagonista
entonces uno necesitaba vestirse de él
si tenía intenciones de sobrevivir
perdón por ahí no saben
estoy preso en la unidad número 48 del
complejo penitenciario de san martín hoy
es uno de mis días de salida transitoria
para qué
para poder subrayar
un poco el tópico de la charla la divide
en pequeños tres bloques
tuve una infancia con mucho amor
y ese amor creo yo
fue el que no me dejó ver las
necesidades primarias de mi familia
a los 13 años ya entrando a la
adolescencia
me convocaron para jugar el fútbol en
las inferiores de un club de primera
división
algunos decían que andaba bien que podía
llegar también estaba cursando el primer
año de la secundaria
estaba feliz
estaba dando mis primeros pasos en el
mundo de los grandes
al tiempo
una noche de esas en donde el sueño no
llega escucho una charla de mis padres
que cambió el rumbo de mi vida
en esta
mi vieja le decía a mi viejo
hay que comprarle botines al negro
porque los que tienen nos dan más
imagina en mi cara la liberación
entonces algo dice la escucha
así expectante esperando la respuesta de
mi viejo
qué dijo
si le compramos o tienes al negro los
otros
no comen por una semana boom
las palabras de mi viejo explotaron en
mi cabeza
en ese preciso instante me daba cuenta
que mi papá
no nos podría mantener a todos
éramos seis hermanos y yo el mayor
al otro día me instale en el boliche de
la vuelta de casa bien temprano en el
bar
ay paraban todos los vagos del barrio y
alrededores
en donde iban y venían en auto robados
y ese día
en el primero que pinto me subí
los pibes intentaron bajarme
pero le dije qué
necesitaba ir
que necesitaba ayudar a mis viejos
y de última para bajarme me tenía que
dar un tiro
los pibes se miraron
se encogieron de hombros
y fuimos ese día
cometí mi primer robo
y empecé a construir una identidad falsa
una identidad que no era mía
una carrera sistemática en donde el
delito categoriza a las personas
y para existir
entras en un círculo en donde la vida
rueda
a otra velocidad
y ya no puedes parar
al tiempo que hay prisa
en esa época te llevaban enseguida del
tribunal de menores
donde se tomaban los datos personales y
al toque te mandaban en instituto
yo y un hombre trucha
necesitaba atrasar lo más posible
la noticia mis viejos
y eso de las 2 de la tarde más o menos
estaba bajando en un instituto de plata
el edificio quedaba como unos 60 metros
del alambrado perimetral que era un
metro y medio de altura aproximadamente
patrullero se posó al lado de un jaulón
de una jaula de tres por tres y me
metieron ahí con otros cuatro pibe más
al rato vino un maestro gordo grandote y
pelado
que nos sacó de la jaula nos paró así en
frente de un portón verde
que parecía la boca de un gigante
y los dijo
escuché bien pedazos de ratas
si alguno de ustedes tiene intenciones
de irse ahora es el momento
porque después que crucen ese portón es
mi responsabilidad y les puedo asegurar
yo
que no van a salir hasta que hasta que
no vienen a buscar sus padres
bueno la verdad que yo las última
palabra no sé si las escuché o las
imágenes porque me pegué media vueltas a
las chapas
los primeros metros apreté los ojos bien
fuerte esperando un tiro en la espalda
pero eso no sucedió
cuando volvió a abrir los ojos ya tenía
la alhambra y
pero salte de un asno solo salto
apoyando la mano izquierda y dejando una
secuela y corrí
corrí corrí no sé por cuánto tiempo
hasta que me di cuenta que no me seguía
a nadie
recupere el rumbo
y volví a casa en todo el camino iba
diciéndome ahora cuando se entera en tus
riesgos te matan y encima después se
mueren de la vergüenza
sigue a mi barrio eso de las 10 de la
noche
mi asombro fue ver a todos los pibes en
las esquinas bueno casi a todos que
cuando me vieron me abrazaban y me
felicitaban porque me había escapado
hoy a la distancia
puedo ver qué
eso fue el primer eslabón para construir
la columna delictiva en la que tuve
sumergido durante toda mi vida
bueno vuelvo
ahora que saben un poco más quién soy y
de dónde vengo
los primeros dos años de esta causa
miraba el muro del penal donde estaba y
decía constantemente
en cualquier momento los altos
en donde están en me voy
así todos los días como queriéndome
convencer
hasta que un día me di cuenta de que no
le iba a saltar nunca me estaba
mintiendo y no podía seguir con eso
necesitaba crear un plan b
y alguna otra alternativa
en ese momento casualidad o señal de la
vida vaya uno a saber pasa frente a mí
ahora coordinadora de educación
de la unidad número 21 de campana donde
estaba alojado en ese momento
aplicación la idea
la educación me iba a ayudar a saltar el
muro antes
estudiar
y va a ser la llave para encontrar mi
libertad
empezó un mes más tarde
como de adolescente había hecho primer
año no me fue difícil enseguida me puse
a ritmo
terminé el secundario con 910 de
promedio
la verdad no quería estudiar
yo lo único que quería era salir lo
antes posible de ese lugar de elegidos
después moleste a mi tribunal durante
dos años para que me trasladaran a la
unidad número 48 donde funciona el
gusano
una unidad académica y valga la
redundancia de la secretaría académica
de la universidad de san martín
con tanta suerte que cuando logró el
traslado ese año no había cpu's un curso
de preparación universitaria
y para convertir el tiempo muerto en
tiempo útil
ya no te en los talleres de poesía y de
narración oral
dictados en ese momento por christina
domenech y el mono jose luis gállego
hoy mis maestros y mis amigos
y ahí me reencontré con la escritura y
con la literatura viva
y me empecé a dar cuenta del valor
y la potencia que puede adquirir la
palabra
al año siguiente empecé la carrera
hoy estoy cursando el tercer año de
licenciatura en sociología y en cada
materia que metía
caiga una ficha a veces más de una
y la educación
empezó a dar su estocada final
la educación empezó a despertar esas
neuronas dormidas
y poco a poco empezó a dejarme pistas
para que pueda haber
cómo funciona el mundo y sus cambios
y esa identidad falsa que adquirí en
algún momento para existir
empezó a desvanecerse
y atrás de ella
empezó a emerger el que siempre fue
y por esas cosas de la vida no pude
desarrollar antes
hoy
hoy dicen que soy poeta y escritor
título que me otorgan por haber
publicado dos libros tres personajes en
mi barrio un libro de historias de
cuentos que recién me entero es tango
está dotado y un poemario titulado agua
quemada que espero tengan oportunidad de
leer y encontrar poesía
pero yo hoy necesito algo más
necesito señalar los puntos donde
descanso la educación
indicando un camino
necesito volver a ver cómo la educación
desplaza las lógicas dominantes y te
otorga herramientas
para que puedas intervenir el mundo en
busca de uno
en donde podamos vivir todos
quiero volver a ver como la educación de
sacar la máscara a ese dicho popular que
dice que la oportunidad viaja en un tren
y que pasa solamente una vez en la vida
eso es mentira sigue la educación eso es
mentira
y para eso crea unos lentes especiales
para que puedas distinguir ver y crear
tus propias oportunidades
la educación transforma a las personas
y las hace seres reflexivos
y cuando se asegura que
vos sos un ser reflexivo
frente a esa fuerte
y te dice lo yo
a partir de hoy
dejo de darte certezas
porque empiezo a formular te preguntas
a mí la educación
me ayudó a saltar los muros de la cárcel
hoy sigue ayudándome a derribar otros
a mí la educación me dio la oportunidad
de elegir
a mí la educación señoras y señores
a mí la educación me dio la oportunidad
de ser libre
cucharas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah